[Music]
hi my name is Francisco and today I want
to show you how to make this vintage
sign actually the sign is new I just
itched it it's yeah why would it look
and making a template are pretty easy I
will show you how you can do it yourself
you will need a piece of untreated wood
some carpet in the same size the
printout of the text you want do you
wool from the hardware store with
vinegar
coffee powder and hot water paint and a
sponge a box cutter and utility gloves
glue your printer text onto the
cardboard cut along the letters with a
box cutter punish all of the letters out
of the cardboard
there's your template now we'll create
the die to give the water whether it's
used look put the steel wool into a
container and pour vinegar in until it's
covered
if you have a cover close the container
pour hot water on the coffee and stir it
you can use instant coffee to let the
coffee and steel was sit for a couple of
days the longer you wait the darker the
dye gets then pull the two liquids
together use the mix to paint the wood
all over
don't forget the edges and don't worry
the smell won't last long once it's dry
use a brush to remove the coffee grounds
now Center your template on the piece of
wood use tape to fix it on the side if
you have footy use it to get an even
firmer fit if not roll up some tape in
my case the O'Hare to be glued down with
pudding now use a sponge to get the
paint mix around the template go over
the template several times be sure to
press the template onto the wood firmly
so the diet doesn't see use a brush to
paint the controls more precisely if you
like then remove the template and remove
any tape or pudding and there it is your
brand spanking new vintage sign if you
want your sign to look even older
pounded it with a hammer or put in a few
nail holes and if you would like it to
look more grey without the coffee and
just use the vinegar steel wool mix